[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde florence merci
pour l'invitation
je parle pas comme ça comme ça tu
arrêtes de m'imiter la csu je peux pas
m'en je peux pas m'empêcher ouais mais
bon c'est ma preuve ce césar et je
t'avoue sam & paper en confiance ça
aurait pu le mettre en confiance et
peut-être d'enfiler un smoking
je veux dire ne pas venir en pigeant là
c'était un peu dur là parce que c'est ma
tenue de scène et ben je les design et
moi même avec ma petite soeur que
j'embrasse des yeux qui pousse tu as vu
ce qui arrive parfois
ça va aller je te promets écoute ma kou
kou et toutes les familles 1
allez bonne chose ok bah je vais essayer
de motos rebooster alors salut moi c'est
stéphane 52 printemps et je suis hyper
content d'être là ce soir pour remettre
le césar de la meilleure musique
originale
alors je suis d'autant plus bas touchés
car bon j'suis pas ce qu'ils au 1
mais je m'appelle le site david boring
et oui chanteur américain du groupe
naive new beaters qui est d'ailleurs mon
groupe
bref de la life et ben qu'on peut
applaudir un peut réussir que des papes
[Applaudissements]
bon je relaxe je suis pas là pour
replacer ma musique convient déjà d'eau
tendre deux fois donc merci de la sacem
ni pour faire la promo de mon groupe
naïve new beaters qui vient d'ailleurs
de sortir son quatrième et excellent
album funhouse une capsule de bonheur en
primaire à la fnac en ce moment avec des
titres comme ou encore le heat
imparable
[Musique]
mme suu kyi
mais je peux témoigner avec mes amis s'y
présente derrière moi dans mon dos que
composer un album composé une musique de
film mais c'est du taf
ingénieur
arrangeur musicien
ces métiers de l'ombre car ils
travaillent dans le noir et se couche
tard
quelle dure mission que de transmettre
musicalement raincy les émotions puiser
ranchot m2 disparates sentiments pour
les faire renaître
cinématographiquement
bravo les nommer bravo est ce qu'avec
les nets
beterz
mais je m'étais foutu de réussir à faire
une musique du sud
j'aimais
un petit peu mais mollo sur le solde
or c'est pas comme ça qu'on va les
convaincre la seule fois où nous a
demandé de composer une musique
originale
c'était pour écrire un tube de l'été
pour une pub de jeux à gratter
mais qu'ils aient jamais devenu un tube
de l'été et nous on est toujours là
gratter si le jeu de mot vous me
permettez